bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur les
plateformes du figaro un salut ce soir
particulier à ceux qui nous regardent
depuis quelques jours sur youtube vous
pouvez continuer et bien nous regarder
et à réagir en direct à répondre
également aux questions qui sont posées
sur youtube et faire comme ceux qui nous
regardent et que je salue également sur
le site du figaro vos commentaires et
nous donner vos points de vue vous
pouvez également répondre à la question
aux questions qu'on va opposer sur
twitter celles qu'on va vous poser sur
les 35 heures puisque on en débat ce
soir et sur le fait de les maintenir ou
non pour pallier aux conséquences pour
pallier les conséquences négatives du
coc vide et du confinement
on en débat avec sophie de menthon
bonsoir sophie bouchet lanceuse
notamment de l'événement j'aime ma boîte
c'est le 15 octobre et tous les détails
sont à retrouver sur le site
j'aime ma boîte points comme face à vous
adriana tout journaliste à marianne
marianne qui pose en une cette question
cette semaine face au co vide
faut-il tout accepter on en débat tout
de suite j'ajoute que l'autre question
qu'on pose ce soir c'est si le tour de
france est trop polluant trop macho
comme le dénonce le maire écolo de lyon
alors est ce que dans ses déclarations
il faut voir une folie de plus d'un
maire écolo ou un vrai tabou qui est
levée et bien on en débat et on en débat
avec vous mais d'abord une question
faut-il allonger la durée du temps de
travail pour relancer l'économie après
la crise du colis de 10,9 c'est la
question quand vous posez la fois sur
youtube
et quand vous pose sur twitter vous
votez vous commenter la question on vous
la pause après cette passe d'armes entre
le patronat d'un côté les syndicats de
l'autre entre en date dernier derniers
échanges en date
geoffroy roux de bézieux pour le medef
et surtout laurent berger ce matin pour
la cfdt la richesse d'un pays
c'est la quantité de travail par
individu multiplié par le nombre de gens
qui travaillent tout le reste c'est
l'idéologie donc ce débat sur le travail
et davantage nous l'aurons dans le cadre
du dialogue social sur les retraites
pas maintenant c'est certain la priorité
c'est la relance mais pas non plus en
mais est ce qu'il faut que les
travailleurs travaillent plus au moment
où on annonce 750000 destructions
d'emplois depuis janvier sept cent mille
jeunes qui vont arriver sur le marché du
travail qui va avoir beaucoup de mal à
en trouver
l'apprentissage qui n'en repart pas les
suppressions d'emplois massives la vraie
question allait de travailler tous et
travailler mieux
elle est sûrement pas de travailler plus
on joue sans exaspérer sophie de menthon
quand vous entendez laurent berger juste
vous poser une question ceci dit quand
on voit mille emplois supprimés chez
auchan se dit que effectivement c'est
pas trop la priorité de rallonge
alors vous allez me pardonner je vais
vous dire que la question est mal posée
la question comment je vais y répondre
c'est comme si tout le monde faisait du
37 il s'agit pas de travailler dans tous
les secteurs toutes les entreprises
toutes les tailles d'entreprises un peu
plus avec les sacro-saints nombreuses
heures là il s'agit de bosser plus pour
sa boîte quand il y en a besoin en ce
moment et il faut alors maintenant c'est
pas une règle à changer immédiatement
institutionnellement d'abord moi si
j'avais quelque chose à faire je
supprimerai les rtt alerte et est encore
une invention unique en france unique au
monde où bien des rtt
voilà ça ça divise encore plus le le
temps de travail ces débats concerts
récupérer et puis je vais mettre mes rtt
avec le pont et puis si j'ai un viaduc
ça va être formidable tous âges je pense
qu'en ce moment ça paraît assez
surréaliste et puis le point qui me qui
m'énerve beaucoup c'est qu'on considère
en france que le travail est à gâteau
c'est ce que disait laurent berger qui
t'a dit rien à gâteau donc on le coupe
donc à ce moment là il faut travailler
29 heures pour que tout le monde est un
petit peu de travail avec la même taille
du gâteau
ce n'est pas vrai il ya des entreprises
qui vont avoir à bosser beaucoup plus
regarder les hôpitaux les malheureux
c'est comme si vous disiez que les
hôpitaux il travaille plus oui en ce
moment il ya des secteurs où travaillent
plus donc arrêtons c'est une erreur
économique
j'aimerais bien que tous ceux qui nous
écoutent le le latex
ce n'est pas plus vous travaillez plus
le gâteau s'agrandit voilà en gros et
donc il y aura plus de travail pour tout
le monde
alors justement on va poser la question
à babineau thucydide olympe avec respect
qu'ils nous rejoignent sur le site du
figaro ou bien weeks et josien sur
youtube
on attend d'avoir vos réactions mais on
va demander sa réaction d'abord à adria
j'ajoute à par rapport à ce que dit
sophie que sur l'histoire des rtt c'est
une vraie question
on a dernièrement notamment cet été un
tas de personnes qui avaient déjà
travaillé ou télétravail et beaucoup
pendant le confinement et qui n'ont pas
pris les vacances sur toute les vacances
auxquelles elles avaient elles avaient
droit
dans les faits pour elle les les 35
heures c'est déjà fini travail déjà
beaucoup beaucoup plus je peux vous
donner un exemple de vous dire que
justement les 35 heures n'existent pour
plus grand monde aujourd'hui puisque le
temps effectif de travail des français
est largement super aux 35 heures je
crois que c'était nicolas sarkozy en
2011 qui avaient dit les 35 heures
n'existent plus et en vérité je pense
que la question du temps de travail
réglementaire est vraiment secondaire
dans ce public à pardo barça dépend
encore 35 heures mais ça va venir
ça dépend lesquels la durée légale du
travail de 35 heures mais les heures
supplémentaires sont de nouveau
défiscalisées depuis début 2010 9 ce qui
ce qui en fait tu supprimes de facto la
quasi totalité du coût des 35 heures
pour les entreprises et alors j'ajoute
sur la question du gâteau c'est un peu
plus compliqué que ça quand même parce
que je ne vois pas pourquoi
mécaniquement le fait que les français
travailleraient tous 45 heures par
semaine créerait des emplois
supplémentaires
la vérité c'est que si nous permet à
tous les français de travailler plus
voilà par exemple en brisant le cas
recommandé qu'un des 35 heures
mécaniquement il ya des gens qui vont
perdre leur emploi pendant le quotidien
même malheureusement beaucoup on peut
craindre qu'ils se retrouvent sur le
carreau quand ça va reprendre puisque il
y aura le compassion du temps de travail
des salariés qui ont déjà un emploi et
que on crée une forme de chômage de
longue durée chez des gens qui auraient
pu en trouver
alors désolé je reprend la métaphore du
gâteau mais qui aurait pu en trouver si
on était resté aux 35 heures mais
au-delà de ça j'ai l'impression que
vraiment le débat mal posé il faut quand
même donner quelques chiffres parce que
sinon on parle de rien l'osce et 2 sec
1/10 chiffres sur le travail elle pas
celle débâcle est posée par notre
j'ai fait les partenaires sociaux à jean
forte baisse depuis qu'il a posé et
laurent berger qui a réagi que c'est
tellement raison dans sa formule en
disant que api n'existe que par la somme
du travail des gens qui travaillent
justement justement l'os et de conques
le nombre d'heures travaillées par an la
france est à 1626 heures travaillées
c'est quand même plus que la marque plus
que les pays bas beaucoup plus que
l'allemagne est quasiment 200 heures de
plus que les allemands alors que mon
avis le débat sur le manque de travail
des allemands n'est pas souvent posée et
même si on paye pourtant si on parle de
productivité alors c'est étrange parce
que en nombre de jours travaillés c'est
pas du tout le cas on travaille moins
n'a plus de vacances que tout ce bruit
mais on est sûr on est sûr plus d'heures
donc
oui de fait les français travaillent
plus il ya aussi plus de productivité
les français sont quand même 15 points
au-dessus de la moyenne européenne en
matière de productivité à cause des 35
heures d'ailleurs grâce je sais pas si
c'est je sais pas non plus mais en tout
cas ce que ça les fatigue vous avez
réseau grâce ou à cause est une vraie
question
parce que c'est vrai que lorsqu'on s'est
mis aux 35 heures on allait la
standardiste elle travaille 35 heures on
n'allait pas recruter une standardiste
pour deux heures dans une pme donc là
donc on a filé la même charge de travail
je me suis dit ça doit pas créer plus de
travail en l'occurrence non desservies
ans de plus de travail pour les salariés
aux places ça a créé plus de stress non
en tout cas j'ai l'impression que le
débat est un petit peu périphériques au
temps de travail en tant que tel puisque
par exemple en allemagne là en ce moment
le grand débat en allemagne lancé par le
plus grand syndicat de salariés
allemands c'est justement la réduction
du temps de travail pour éviter de
perdre des emplois
donc je suis pas sûr que les 35 heures
sont bien en allemagne déjà 40 alors ça
dépend des branches mais là dans la
branche métallurgie il propose de faire
des accords à 28 heures par semaine pour
les salariés donc je pense vraiment pas
si c'est vraiment de quoi et à mesure ça
c'est palace
là on est d'accord sur ça c est le fait
de sa quelquechose d'uniformes surtout
sur toute l'économie ce n'est pas
forcément une bonne idée est en jeu et
c'est encore la manche a continué c'est
très intéressant parce que vous répondre
à une question justement de cet
internaute sur youtube qui nous dit
l'unique question à se poser est qu'est
que disent les
les dix les études effectivement les
études sont plus nuancés que les
positions des uns des uns et des autres
mais dans ce que l'on danse que l'on
voit il ya une autre question qui est
posée sous jacente c'est sa voix est ce
que c'est la priorité ou pas là tout le
monde est d'accord la fois les
partenaires de chez les partenaires
sociaux aujourd'hui c'est pas encore une
priorité
j'en sais rien
c'est à dire que je n'en sais rien
encore une fois j'ai des entreprises où
tout le monde ya une agence de pub
il ya pas mal de gens qui sont absents
etc il ya un budget on va travailler
beaucoup plus vallat les forces
commerciales elles sont obligées de
mettre les bouchées doubles un bon
vendeur vous pouvez pas c'est compliqué
un bon vendeur elle met les bouchées
doubles il faut rattraper chiffre
d'affaires j'ai vu des restaurateurs et
les coiffeurs tiens il reste ouvert
beaucoup plus tard ils ont perdu un
chiffre d'affaires et ils en profitent
d'ailleurs ses revenues au début et ça
revient beaucoup moins
donc il y à là la nécessité de répondre
à la demande du client
malheureusement d'ailleurs n'y a pas
tellement de demandes en ce moment c'est
pour ça que quand il y en a fait se
précipiter et je dois dire que il n'y a
pas de réponse unilatérale pour ça
franchement faut-il allonger la durée du
temps de travail pour relancer
l'économie après la crise du coït 10,9
pour l'instant sur twitter en tout cas
vous êtes une large majorité à répondre
non alors la question c'est de savoir
pourquoi quelles sont les raisons que
que vous apportez j'ai pas on n'a pas
parlé de la fonction publique on n'a pas
parlé de non plus de l'armée qui
échappent pour l'instant
aux règles du 35 heures 2e nous dit pour
le moment ce n'est pas le travail
c'est pas le travail c'est le co vice
doit-on craindre le pire pour la suite
du coronavirus je ne supporte plus de
travailler dans cette atmosphère de fin
du monde et je n'y pense qu'on s'appuie
trop sur le qui vive pour voter de
nouvelles lois le coc vide a bon dos
c'est ce que je me dis plus on avance
dans le temps il ya une autre chose qui
est soulevée puisque vous parliez
justement des des différences entre les
secteurs des besoins en temps de travail
selon les secteurs
il ya une autre piste qu'a abordé qu'à
soulever ce matin une autre suggestion
tous les cas qui a été faite ce matin
par laurent berger et je vous propose de
l'écouter on en n'est pas tout de suite
après c'est vite et elle pousse l'idée
d'une banque des temps elle pousse cette
idée d'un compte épargne temps universel
qui permettrait de faire des pauses à
des moments donnés dans cette dans sa
carrière il plus certaines années de sa
vie au début pourquoi potentiellement et
la vie active guillemets y compris avec
un système de dépeindre solidaire entre
les salariés
certains travaillent variable en
fonction de l'âge par exemple oui et
qu'on pourrait faire un peu au libre
choix vous savez on est quand même un
pays un peu bizarre qui encore une fois
concentre une intensification du travail
entre eux en gros 30 ans et 50 ans
peut-être qu'on peut gérer les choses
différemment
alors je vous ai entendu encore soufflé
ce film un sommet c'est noël c'est
dommage que vous voyez pas pendant le
pendant qu'il fait pourtant tant les
frais parce que vous auriez vu la
réaction de sophie de menthon donc
sophie de menthon et exaspère encore
d'entendre laurent berger mais pourtant
quand je vous ai entendu tout à l'heure
je vous dis que c'était quand même
plutôt en rapport avec ce que est ce que
vous disiez le code civil et j'ai réagi
aux chefs d'entreprise c'est de toute
façon épidermique le compte épargne
temps
oui c'est vrai c'est épidermique de
caunes épargne temps pour le salarié
c'est très bien c'est vrai après tout je
vais travailler à tel moment je choisis
c'est à la carte l'économie d'un pays et
la gestion d'une entreprise c'est pas du
boulot à la carte
je veux dire que moi j'ai connu ça
j'irais directeur général le directeur
général de mon entreprise
elle est formidable elle m'a fait cet
enfant si je puis dire elle a fait sept
enfants
elle a pris au total +1 non elle avait
droit parce que plus en prenez etc
je les gardais comme directeur général
je l'aimé énormément j'ai été formidable
et c'était juste épouvantable je pense
que mon entreprise a raté un moment de
développement terrible quand elle arrive
et qu'elle me dit j'attends le cinquième
gens pleuraient 7 c'est beaucoup comme
directeur général c'est beaucoup pour le
chef d'entreprise je sais que ça va
réagir quand vous êtes chef d'entreprise
et que l vous annonce qu'elle atteint le
septième enfant quelle est votre réponse
à tous les parents de familles
nombreuses
mais non vous allez dire que j'adore les
familles nombreuses mais c'est pas
forcément une très très bonne nouvelle
comme au directeur général vous attend
vous dit qu'elle attend son septième
bébé alors c'est mieux de les garder ça
va très bien c'était très bien et c'est
non mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
cette espèce de con de compte épargne
temps ne tient pas compte d'une société
qui va de plus en plus vite ou les
exigences sont de plus en plus fortes où
on est souvent en temps réel où il faut
réagir immédiatement et les salariés
alors là je vais dans le sens des
syndicats je ne trouve pas que ce sont
des pions remplaçable par d'autres pions
quand vous avez quelqu'un de formidable
et qui vous dira pas de là je vais
prendre six mois tient manon c'est très
difficile pour l'entreprise ça risque de
causer un dommage et de nuire et qui est
moins de chiffre d'affaires est moins
d'emploi les salariés c'est marrant
d'ailleurs c'est sur les syndicats qui
considèrent que ce sont des pions qu'on
peut en recruter d'autres l'échangé les
faire travailler moi leur donner de
temps qu'ils veulent maintenant ils ont
une qualité formidable on a besoin d'eux
et c'est vrai que c'est très dur
d'imaginer sauf si c'est très planifiée
pour les retraites etc mais d'imaginer
qu'ils partent quand ils veulent et ils
reviennent quand ils veulent les
modalités juste d'abord ce qu'est ce que
vous pensez de la suggestion de laurent
berger et question subsidiaire sur
l'objection fait justement se fixer
c'est vrai que la question qu'on se pose
en entendant laurent berger c'est ok
mais comment on fait pour les modalités
alors comment en fait je vous dis tout
de suite j'ai pas la réponse parce que
je pense que ce pourrait ça pourrait
être une usine à gaz considérable mais
alors ceci dit je trouve pas la
réflexion idiote quand même parce que
justement
quand on parlait tous les deux du du
fait que plaques et les 35 heures
surtout tous les métiers différents
différemment c'était idiot c'est vrai
que le fait de travailler 35 heures
quand on a 19 ans pas de famille pas
encore de famille ou quand on vient
d'avoir trois enfants alors même si on
avait congé maternité etc
mais je trouve pas ça idiot vraiment
dans l'idée de permettre aux gens de
prendre des années où il s'occupe plus
de leur famille ou je ne sais pas il
consacre plus de temps alors loisirs ou
d'autres où ils vont se dire maintenant
je vais plus travailler ça me paraît
vraiment pas idiot et alors je peux
parler quand même de réagir sur le fait
que oui le monde va vite le monde bouge
etc
mais ça peut pas être toujours la
réponse pour refuser toute avancée
sociale au bout d'un moment c'est le
monde bouge d'accord mais si ça se fait
en bonne intelligence avec les patrons
vous avez raison les arrêts sont pas des
pions qu'on peut déplacer etc
mais si on est sur quelque chose de
prévu d'anticiper avec avec son patron
cela me paraît pas forcément les lancia
parce que les avancées sociales en
france on est leader dans le monde
bah oui c'est très bien d'ailleurs oui
ça j'en fais moi que non plus que ça
nous coûte cher et que ça détruisent des
emplois et que la france recule et c'est
ma seule préoccupation mais oui les
avancées sociales là je vois le congé de
paternité qui a augmenté les on est que
dans des droits et heureusement que les
salariés en particulier des entreprises
et des intermédiaires et les pme je vais
vous dire ils ont un sens de leur
entreprise et qui ne cherchent pas tout
le temps le droit qu'ils pourraient
avoir accès à ce n'est pas le cas leur
mentalité n'est pas celle-là est en
revanche je voudrais qu'on parle un peu
de la fonction publique est quand même à
gigantesque ballon avec que personne de
réforme où l'on parle pas plus
d'avancées sociales que c'est pas
possible
enfin de la rémunération des
fonctionnaires ce depuis depuis une
dizaine d'années c'est quand même pas
non plus si on le rapporte à certaines
masse de travail pour certains
fonctionnaires avec les doublons avec la
la la la charge de travail qu'ils ont
moi je pense qu'il faut affiner leurs
gardes si on prend par exemple l'exemple
mais plein d'exemples les soignants les
politiciens même les professeurs les
enseignants français sont extrêmement
mal payés par rapport à la moyenne
pn et pourtant ils travaillent ils
travaillent beaucoup mais si c'est
dommage vous avez tout à fait raison et
alors dans d'autres pays c'est
formidable soient obligés d'aller
d'entreprise l'était un peu ils ont
besoin de vacances
évidemment oui formidable parce qu elle
pas un prof qui sait ce que c'est que la
vie d'une entreprise et donc ça veut
dire qu'ils sont obligés aux etats-unis
beaucoup en angleterre et c'est de faire
un stage et d'aller voir ce que c'est
que l'entreprise
donc il ya tout un système moi j'étais
effondré de voir un prof l'autre jour
qui me disent j'ai 35 ans était brillant
excellent prof et s'est dit qu'est ce
que je vais faire je suis au sommet de
ma carrière donc ils n'ont pas de
résultats et non pas de prime au bon
résultat
un bon prof n'est jamais encouragé ont
commencé mais la prof c'est difficile
vous plaisantez fait noter les est là
vous allez voir tiens et si messi est en
angleterre c'est les élèves souvent qui
recrutent les profs avec non
oui c'est un autre débat et on peut
parler également du point du gel du
point d'indicé de la fonction publique
mais c'est également un autre débat
nathan nous que je salue qui j'espère il
a retrouvé le sens qu'ils avaient un
point de son on ne doit légiférer nous
dit il ni sur la durée du travail ni sur
le salaire minimum le marché aussi fait
tout ça très bien
en tout cas mieux que l'état c'est votre
point de vue ça sophie bas vous tenter
alors maintenant quand vous dites ça en
france est une catastrophe
on n'en est même pas ce vrai ou pas
c'est vrai mais mais il ya des avancées
sociales et on ne peut pas laisser le
marché complètement dérégulé et payer
les gens selon le besoin et c'est donc
oui il faut protéger des des salariés et
certaines professions cela dit oui le
marché s'occupe bien des choses est que
quand il ya un besoin et des gens
talentueux ils sont payés beaucoup plus
quand il n'ya pas de soi se sont payé
moi et je pense qu'en france on a de
gros efforts à faire car on a quand
odile marché c'est le diable quand on
dit l'état il doit tout c'est lui qui
décide de l'horaire du port des masques
c'est lui qui décide qui doit aller
distribuer aussi les entreprises ont
droit de faire ceci ou cela layton à un
état protecteur qui finit par ne plus
l'être qui est obèse
je sais plus qui disait l'état est
invoquée obèses qu'il faut être sans
cheval c'est l'été le cheval c'est
l'entreprise quel est l'auteur de cette
de cette phase répond cet internaute qui
nous dit qu'on répond pas à cette
question mais la question concerne les
tests pcr et c'est pas là tellement la
question qui se pose ou bien dont une
théorie sur la crise financière sur le
dos du coc vie de 10,9 la chromie la
crise financière je crains entre le cash
à l'internaute qu' elle soit déjà là et
elles soient pas été provoqué par
l'interruption du travail en particulier
de l'activité mondiale au moment de la
crise de coliques 10,9 la bourse la
bourse va bien ça c'est un autre débat
mais et si c'est l'économie c'est un
autre débat
cet internaute qui nous dit je suis
salariée dans une petite entreprise je
gagne le smic abandonné les trans lui il
veut abandonner les 35 heures pour un
retour aux 39 heures mais c'est ce que
vous disiez adrien on n'en est pas loin
aujourd'hui en fait lorsqu'on pratique
avec la fin de la fiscalité sur les
heures supplémentaires
je pense que le monsieur pourrait
travailler 39 heures ça changerait pas
grand chose mais peut-être que son
patron a pas de quoi lui donner donc il
n'y a pas d'heure supplémentaire et
qu'en fait il a envie de gagner plus
c'est possible répondre rapidement à la
question précédente sur le rôle de
l'état et on passe est dû explique à mon
avis ça me paraît extrêmement naïf de
penser que dans une situation où le
chômage est massif
le rapport de forces est naturellement
plus favorable au chef d'entreprise
qu'au potentiel salariés et du coup à
mon avis le smic ou la durée du travail
ce serait plutôt le patron qui
décideraient et le salarié qui seraient
obligés d'accepter puisque le patron lui
dirai naturellement si tu refuses moi
j'ai santos en votre personne qui sont
prêtes à prendre ce travail-là donc à
mon avis c'est un petit peu naïf de
penser que le marché naturellement va va
arriver à un niveau optimal entre
guillemets de smic ou de temps du
travail hebdomadaire alors la citation
hervé sérieyx la france est un pur sang
monté par un jockey obèses qui se prend
pour le cheval la question qui était
posée c'est et faut-il allonger la durée
du temps de travail pour relancer
l'économie après
crise du coc vide 10,9 et vous répondez
non à 61%
l'autre question l'autre débat composent
ce soir concerne le tour de france ou
plus exactement les propos du nouveau
maire de lyon qui doit normalement
accueillir la grande boucle samedi
prochain donc qui a déclaré dans les
colonnes du progrès jeu grégory lui
c'est le tour de france continue à
véhiculer une image machiste du sport le
tour n'est pas éco responsable adrien
dans marianne
il ya un article qui se demandent s'il
ne faut pas chercher aujourd'hui incarne
marx de l'écologie là au moins on avec
mes revers aujourd'hui
alors j'ai toujours du mal avec
l'expression connaît un verre parce que
je n'ai pas content l'impression que
j'ai bien justement j'ai l'impression
que les gens ont oublié un peu ce que
c'était que les moyens rouge quand même
faudrait quand même alors une forme de
mesure les khmers rouges ont quand même
massacrer des gens par centaines de
milliers les vertueux ça n'est pas le
cas des les élus écologique voilà alors
ça vient essayons de prendre au sérieux
l'affirmation de grégory doucet qui
évidemment moi me dérange parce que
c'est toujours le premier rang à montner
baisser le ton c'est toujours un ton qui
fait un peu bourgeois des métropoles
déconnecté qui donne des leçons alors
qu'il ne connaît pas très bien de quoi
il parle l'accusation de machisme alors
on a beaucoup parlé des hôtesses du tour
de france ça me paraît un petit peu
exagéré de dresser un procès en machisme
pour pour cette raison là grégory doucet
a mentionné le fait qu'ils n'avaient pas
de tour de france féminin c'est vrai
mais il va réapparaître en 2022 en fait
donc je sais pas s'il était au courant
mais il va y il va y avoir à nouveau un
tour de france pour les femmes en 2022
alors sur l'aspect écolo pour le coup si
sur le fond il ay là il a plutôt raison
quand même parce que alors les vélos ne
pollue pas ça c'est entendu mais le tour
de france produit des quand même des
déchets absolument considérable c'est
quand même 120 tonnes de déchets sur
près de 3500 km parce que vous avez
quelque chose qui s'appelle la caravane
du tour là où on voit là une série de
camions etc qui lancent des objets en
plastique
on va aller aux gens sur la route la
plupart du temps des objets fabriqués en
chine de très basse qualité bon c'est
pas du tout écolo vous avez 2300
voitures suiveuses
vous avez des hélicoptères pour filmer
le l'action vous avez des car l'écart
des équipes
bon c'est un événement polluants après
résumé le tour de france à cette
dimension là ça me paraît extrêmement
caricaturale
sophie avant de revenir justement sur le
bilan carbone du tour de france soulevée
par adrien et par grégory lui c'est
d'abord vous trouvez que c'est trop
macho moi je match all vélo pas du tout
ça me fascine pas le tour de france mais
c'est un événement extrêmement populaire
et je respecte complètement le plaisir
que prennent les gens à cette
compétition sportive et les écolos ils
auraient don extraordinaire pour rendre
la vie triste tout ce qui peut être gay
sympa c'est pas écolo
donc je pense pas maintenant le machisme
tue exaspéré parce que si c'est une
question de ces ravissantes jeunes
femmes qui viennent embrasser le
vainqueur en tendant la coupe et cetera
oui c'est vrai qu'il ya un côté années
et alors d'abord est ce qu'on a demandé
à ces jeunes femmes si elles sont ravis
qu'on ait supprimé lors leur poste qui
consistait à la compagnie etc
je trouve que c'était une figure de
couple
des hommes des femmes voilà enfin une
fois ce moment là il faut supprimer
toutes les hôtesses dans les salons les
hôtesses de l'air vous supprimez tout ce
qui peut être un peu l'aspect charmes de
la femme parce que c'est les féministes
aime pas ça donc bon ça n'a pas de sens
maintenant je trouve que le football est
un sport beaucoup plus machos si on va
par là parce que c'est un sport qu'est
enfin oui il me semble alors ce que vous
disiez est le rugby sais pas pourquoi je
trouve ça va c'est autre chose mais bon
je suis pas attentats comme je vous dise
un peu plus il ya un peu plus au contact
c'est un peu plus bredouille
c'est vrai plutôt tennis mais bon et
natation mais bon alors ce que vous
disiez est parfaitement exact sur la
pollution que ça génère il faut savoir
aussi que le tour de france il vit à
cause et grâce à des sponsors que ça
fait vivre économiquement à nombre de
gens incroyables que on y viendra
il va falloir 4 5 ans on va plus lancé
d'objets en plastique
on va finir par faire des choses plus
écolo ça va venir
tu as déjà commencé et d'ailleurs je
vois même temps je voudrais citer l'aref
là puisqu'il y avait le ski était
anciennement l'université du medef y
avait plus une bouteille plastique on
avait des bouteilles d'eau on avait des
ça a été complètement là alors là en
deux ans on s'était mis à jour forcément
il fallait donner l'exemple
on aura compris que sophie de menthon m
l'entreprise et lens l'événement j'aime
ma boîte c'est le 15 octobre
je n'ai pas pour elle lucien d'or
parfait donc comme ça tout est fait mais
il n'y a pas de placement de produit à
propos de placements de produits
justement quand même béatrice houchard
qui travaillent à l'opinion notre
concert de l'ancien du figaro a fait
d'avoir un très beau livre qu'on
recommande sur l'éloge du tour de france
en tout cas pour l'écriture on le
recommande
et pour la confraternité aussi et elle
elle signale dans un article paru dans
figaro vox cent mille sacs poubelles en
matières 100% recyclés seront distribués
sont distribués sur les routes à
l'occasion de ce tour de france
50 % de déchets sont recyclés 63 zones
de collecte de déchets réservée aux
coureurs installé neuf coordinateur
environnement dans les caravanes et 29
véhicules de l'organisation hybrides et
des voitures 100% électriques qui sauf
que légalement il ya quand même un
effort qui est fait en matière de
respect de l'environnement
bah oui justement c'est à ça que je
pensais quand je disais que ça va déjà
commencer
vous avez aussi les voitures de
l'organisation qui vont maintenant et
des voitures électriques donc alors en
fait il ya un effort aussi parce que
l'écologie est donné quelque chose de
totalement mainstream et que du coup
c'est un bon élément de communication
pour le tour de dire regardez on fait un
tour au vert ont fait entourer comme
étant leur apportera tant mieux c'est ça
c'est peut-être de l'écologie
opportuniste mais c'est de l'écologie
quand même oui voilà ça montre en tout
cas que il ya une volonté de faire
quelque chose d'un peu plus raisonnable
moi je pense que le problème numéro un
c'est vraiment la caravane du tour
vraiment pour la voir après avoir
assisté c'est quand même un petit peu
anachronique je pense ces camions qui
distribue des centaines d'objets par
terre mais en fait ce qui me gêne c'est
en soi c'est pas de dire que le que le
tour est quelque chose
de polluants c'est de passer à côté de
ce que c'est que le tour en fait le tour
quand les genres pouvait le tour il y
voit pas quelque chose de polluants il
voit un événement le dernier grand
événement gratuit en france le sportif
populaire qui fait l'effort voilà les
objets c'est aussi des souvenirs pour
les bien sûr c'est ce que dit notre ami
notre confrère alors de bfm tv patrick
sauce et qui dit notamment que il a
gardé toujours une grotte qui a été
envoyé par les joueurs venir quand ils
étaient 1 quand il regardait enfant le
bien surpasser le tournant science alors
pour les gens qui adorent le vélo c'est
un sport incroyable à la fois collectif
et individuel où il ya des valeurs de
solidarité de courage pour les gens qui
n'aiment - le vélo ils peuvent quand
même regarder à la télé parce qu'il ya
tout patrimoine architectural et
paysages français qui sont représentés
donc franchement très beau commenté
franck ferrand voilà exactement
donc je pense qu'en fait le grégory
doucet son erreur là c'est que les verts
subissent un procès comme quoi ils
seraient des bobos il est connecté
ouais mais surtout des bobos déconnecté
des métropoles qui n'ont pas de
connexion avec les avec la france
populaire et en fait il donne le bâton
pour se faire battre avec sans compter
que quand même ce moment le vélo est le
moyen de locomotion recommandé par tout
le monde
imposer à paris au delà de l'imaginable
et que ce moyen que tout le monde peut
s'approprier
ça redonne justement le sais tu n'as
citation du tour de france à faire du
vélo jeux sur facebook et sur le site du
figaro pour retrouver le sujet signé
deux brunes d'audrey qui interroge sur
le vélo en ville ce qu'il est possible
d'avoir une ville 100% vélo sujet
retrouver donc sur la page facebook du
figaro et dans l'onglet vidéo également
sur le site du figaro à la rubrique
facture on se souvient pas mais en 1924
le parti communiste avait lancé dans
l'humanité une campagne de
stigmatisation contre le tour mais
preuve immoral et qui fustigeait des
salles dessous des entreprises
commerciales les moeurs sportif
bourgeoise et les maquignonnage
ignominieux des mercantis du sport
depuis le du mas a fait
l'hiver c'est une idée caricature sexy
ce serait championne notamment mes potes
complet et honnête
ajoutons que le quotidien a retiré a
présenté ses excuses à marion hamard ils
ont surtout essayer d'organiser le tour
après la seconde guerre mondiale donc il
avait changé d'avis sur le cyclisme mois
ci à propos de famille c'est pas jeannie
longo récemment vie à la championne de
vélo alors vous demanderez peut-être au
jeu ce soir c'est le suisse marc hirschi
qui s'est imposé donc en solitaire dans
le sprint qui était l'étape du jour et
s'est imposé ce qui s'est imposée parce
que ça va mieux aujourd'hui c'était à
saran donc qui est quand même le symbole
effectivement de la france rurale et la
france chez de la france chiraquienne
les écologistes enfantile trop en
considérant le tour de france comme une
tradition machiste et polluantes et la
réponse est oui à 68% je vous le livre
juste ce qu'est ce
oui oui à 68 pour ça oui non pardon
pardon c'est à 85 point à 80 3% mais je
le voyais dedans à 84% pardonnez moi
c'était à 80% au début de nos débuts de
au début au début de au début des débats
pardonnez moi je fais mea culpa monde
honorable
jamy nous disait justement sur twitter
les écolos sont des fous dans son point
de vue qui veulent ramener les français
au moyen âge alors oui faisons attention
mais pas en privation loisirs déjà les
cirques les parcs animaliers des loisirs
sur l'eau car on pollue et c est ce que
également derrière ce que dit jeune il
n'ya pas effectivement
le problème de cette écologie punitive
messi et je vais vous dire les écolos
sont les plus pire ambassadeur
l'écologie je suis une écolo mais ils me
dégoûtent de l'écologie on apprend tout
le jeu mais oui je suis une écolo enfin
je fais des petits gestes qui n'ont pas
d'intérêt peut-être mais le triche mais
attention je fais du vélo dans paris
j'ai ma voiture est définitivement gars
et je la sors une fois par an je fais
attention à ce que j'achète vraiment et
je ramasse jeûner le mois mam hammam je
suis prêt tu as à me battre pour le
plastique contre le plastique dans les
mers qui est pour moi quelque chose
d'effroyable donc nous le sommes nous
sommes tous malgré eux et je pense que
c'est une écologie punitive punitive et
dissuasive
l'avocat des écolos pour le coup bien
que ça aussi on aura tout vu
je ne suis pas totalement convaincu par
par les initiatives des écolos mais je
pense qu'il ya quand même une une
fâcheuse tendance je pense quand même a
refusé d'admettre que parmi nos loisirs
parmi ce qui nous fait plaisir parmi ce
qu'on aime il ya quand même des
activités certaines pas tout
ou des pratiques qui quand même rentrer
en totale contradiction avec l'impératif
écologique qui est quand même d'une
urgence absolue fin janvier quand même
les gens à regarder un petit peu les
données scientifiques et à prendre la
mesure de ce qui peut nous attendre dans
l'île dans les prochaines années
et alors chez moi je suis pas forcément
sur des événements sportifs localisée
mais par exemple on avait eu un on avait
eu beaucoup de débats sur le fait de
limiter les vols à l'intérieur du
territoire
moi je pense que par exemple le fait
d'être privé de faire un paris marseille
en avion passait pas forcément la
conséquence de
les khmers verts quoi ceux qui veulent
faire paris marseille et par exemple les
gens qui travaillent dans des
entreprises qui sont des entreprises
internationales et qui sont obligés de
prendre qui habite par exemple marseille
bordeaux comme ça et qu'ils doivent
doivent rejoindre leurs rangs
new york justement justement je pense
qu'on doit avoir une réflexion sur le
fait que quand il ya une alternative
plus écologique est par exemple par et
mars est en train c'est pas beaucoup
plus long que par mrc en avion je pense
qu'il faut vraiment qu'on est quand même
une réflexion c'est le même exemple pour
les cirques en fait les cirques avec des
animaux - il ya dix ans j'aurais trouvé
ça complètement délirant de vouloir
arrêter les animaux dans les cirques et
bien en y réfléchissant en garde en
regardant de plus près je trouve ça pas
si idiot donc à mon avis on devrait
aussi du côté des gens qui sont plus
sceptiques envers les écolos peut-être
se retenir de hurler aux khmers verts à
chaque sortie et se dire est ce que là
il délire ou est-ce que là peut-être il
ya une question qu'on ne s'était pas
posée et qui pourrait être intéressante
bon je sais pas si vous avez convaincu
les internautes du figaro par votre père
votre part sur plaidoyer en faveur des
écologistes
donc les écologistes ans font plus trop
en considérant le tour de france comme
une tradition machiste je cite et
polluantes ce sont les mots de grégory
douce et le maire de lyon eh bien vous
répondez oui oui ils en font trop à 83,5
% ce pas un sondage c'est une question
babineau qui nous dit et rock europe
ecologie les verts n'a pas le monopole
de l'écologie on peut être tous écolos à
notre niveau et bien ce soir vous
l'étiez tous les trois babineau adrien
et sophie de menthon et bien sûr bien
sûr et
à défendre l'environnement la nature la
culture et le patrimoine c'est la marque
de figaro live je signale donc les
événements à ne pas manquer c'est j'aime
ma boîte c'est le 15 octobre prochain
et ça c'est pas de placement produit
c'est gratuit et avec donc j'aime ma
boîte points comme tous les détails
et puis le dernier numéro de marianne
qui vient juste de la grâce de paraître
qui est pas gratuit mais on le paye ça
ça vaut le coup de payer avec plaisir et
qui est consacré donc encore une fois je
vais dire au qu'ovide face au co vide
faut-il tout accepter et c'est un numéro
un dossier passionnant
on se retrouve demain même heure même
endroit ici même avec guillaume roquette
a très vite sur figure live